We've learned in
previous videos that
relative to the orbital
plane around the sun
or the plane of Earth's
orbit around the sun,
the Earth has a certain tilt.
So let me draw the Earth's tilt
relative to that orbital plane
right over here.
So this if this is the
orbital plane right over here
so we're looking right directly
sideways on this orbital plane
that I've drawn in orange.
And maybe at the point
in Earth's orbit right
now, maybe the sun
is to the left,
and so the rays from
the sun are coming
in this general direction.
We've learned that the
Earth as a certain tilt,
and when I mean that
it means if you think
about the axis around which
it's rotating it's not straight
up from the orbital
plane, it is at an angle.
And let me draw that.
So if I were to draw an arrow
that's coming out of the North
Pole it would look like that.
And maybe I'll draw an arrow
coming out of the South Pole.
And the Earth is rotating in
that direction right over here,
and you notice this axis that
I've drawn this arrow on,
it is not straight up and down.
And right now it is at
an angle of 23.4 degrees
with the vertical, with
being straight up and down.
And we've learned
how this is what
is the primary
cause of our seasons
in that when the Northern
Hemisphere is pointed
towards the sun it's getting
a disproportionate amount
of the solar radiation.
Whatever's going through
the atmosphere has
to go through less atmosphere
and the things in the Northern
Hemisphere are
getting more daylight.
And when the Earth is on
the other side of the sun
and the Northern
Hemisphere is pointed away
from the sun then the
opposite is going to happen.
And the reverse is true for
the Southern Hemisphere.
But in that video
when we talk about how
tilt can affect
the seasons, I also
kind of hinted a little bit
that this is the current tilt
right now, and over
long periods of time
that this tilt will change.
And in particular, it will
vary, and even the boundaries
for this varying are different
for the past million years
than they will be for
the next million years,
but it varies roughly between
22.1 degrees and 24.5 degrees.
And just to make it
clear that it's not
wobbling back and
forth like this,
and just to visualize
22.1 versus 24.5,
it's not a huge difference.
So if this is 23.4-- and
I'm not measuring exactly--
maybe pointing in this
direction, maybe 22.1
would look something like that.
In fact, I've exaggerated it.
And maybe 24.5 would
look something like that.
And so it's not a
huge difference,
but it is enough of a difference
so we believe to actually
have a significant impact
on what the climate is like
or what the seasons
are like, especially
in terms of how much of a chance
different parts of our planet
have a chance to freeze
over or not freeze over
and all the rest, or how
much sunlight they get
and all the rest.
So it has some
impact, but I want
to make it clear that it
takes a long period of time.
That it actually
takes 41,000 years
to go from a minimum
tilt to a maximum tilt
and then back to a minimum tilt.
41,000 years.
And right now at a
tilt of 23.4 degrees,
we're someplace right
smack in between.
And we think the last
maximum was at 8,700 BCE,
before the common era, or
you could say before Christ.
And that the next minimum, when
our tilt has been minimized,
the next time our
tilt will be minimized
will be in the year 11,800.
So this isn't something
that's happening overnight,
but it is something
that could affect
our climate over
long periods of time.
And this is just one
factor, and sometimes
this changing of the tilt,
a fancier word for tilt
is sometimes given,
is obliquity,
but this is really just
a fancy word for tilt.
This changing of the obliquity--
or the changing of the tilt--
is one of these changes in
Earth's rotation or Earth's
orbit around the sun that
might have long-term cycles
or effects on Earth's
climate, and maybe they
do help cause certain ice
ages when they act together
with each other
over certain cycles.
And broadly, this
entire class of cycles
are called Milankovitch cycles.
Milankovitch, he was
a Serbian scientist,
who's the guy who theorized that
these changes in Earth's orbit
might be responsible
for long-term climate
change or maybe some cycles
where we enter ice ages
and get out of ice
ages or we have
more extreme or less
extreme weather.
So these are
Milankovitch cycles.
And changes in the tilt,
or the elbow obliquity,
are just one of the
possible factors
playing into
Milankovitch cycles.
And what I want to do in this
video and in the next video
is talk about all of
the different factors,
or at least summarize all
of the different factors.
Now, another one.
This one is pretty intuitive for
me that this tilt can change.
One that's a little bit less
intuitive when you first
think about it is something
called precession.
And the idea behind
precession, I
guess the best analogy
I can think of,
is if you imagine
a top, or maybe you
could imagine Earth as
a top right over here.
The top is spinning, the top
is spinning in this direction,
and obliquity tells
you, essentially,
how much it's wobbling.
Actually, let me
think of it this way.
Imagine a wobbling top.
So it's rotating like
this, it's tilted,
and then it is
also if you imagine
that this was a pole up here
that's coming out of the pole,
that this was actually
a physical arrow,
that that arrow itself
would be rotating.
So the best way to think
about it is a wobbling top.
If you think after
some point of time
this thing would wobble so
it would look like this.
So now the arrow is
pointing that way.
And if you wait a
few more seconds now
maybe the arrow is pointing
a little bit out of the page.
And then you wait a
few more seconds then
it's pointing in this direction,
it's pointing into the page.
And so this whole time, the
obliquity isn't changing.
The obliquity you can view
it as how far is that wobble.
You could imagine how far
from vertical is that wobble,
and no matter where we
are in that rotation
it hasn't changed, and you
could imagine the precession
as where we are in the wobble.
And I want to-- this is a
little bit hard to visualize,
and hopefully, as we think
about it in different ways
and I draw different
diagrams it'll
become a little bit clearer--
but I want to make it clear.
Just as it takes a long
time for the inclination
to change from a minimum value
to a maximum value and back,
it takes a huge amount of
time for Earth's precession
to change in a significant way.
So for this top to-- if you
imagined this arrow popping
out, for this arrow to actually
trace out an entire loop,
it takes 26,000 years.
So 26,000 years to have an
entire cycle of precession.
Now, what I want to
do is think about
given that this
precession is occurring,
I want to think about how
that would affect our seasons,
or how it would
actually affect how
we think about the
year or the calendar.
So let's draw the orbit
of Earth around the sun.
So here is my sun
right over here.
And here is the orbit of Earth.
And I'm not going
to think too much--
I'm going to assume
that it's almost
circular for the
sake of this video.
In future videos,
we'll talk about how
the eccentricity-- or how
elliptical the orbit is--
can also affect the
Malinkovitch cycles
or play into the
Malinkovitch cycles.
But let's just draw the orbit of
Earth around the sun over here.
And so you could imagine this
is, at one point in time,
this is the Earth.
Let's say it is tilted
towards the sun right now.
And so is in the
Northern Hemisphere--
and I'm assuming this
arrow is coming out
of the North Pole-- this would
be the summer in the Northern
Hemisphere.
And then if you had no
precession, absolutely
no precession, when you
go to this time of year
you still have the
same direction of tilt.
Let me do that in blue.
You still have the
same direction of tilt.
We're still pointing to the
same part of the universe.
We still have the
same North Star.
You go to this time, we're still
tilting in the same direction
relative to the
universe, but we're not
tilting away from the sun.
And now this would be the winter
in the Northern Hemisphere.
And we'd keep going around.
And if you had no
precession, when you get back
to this point over
here, we'd be tilting
in the exact same direction.
If your obliquity or if your
tilt changed a little bit,
you might move up or
down, away, or towards
the sun a little bit, but this
is all assuming no precession.
Now, I'm going to
think about what
happens if you do
have precession.
So what's happening
with precession
is when you go around
one time around the sun,
by the time you get
to this point again
you're not pointing at
exactly the same direction.
You are now pointing
a little bit further
so this arrow-- let me draw
it a little bit bigger.
So this is the Earth
and this is that arrow.
And this is hard to visualize
or at least it's hard for me
to visualize.
Well, once you get it,
it's easier to visualize,
but the first time I
tried to understand it,
it was hard for me to
understand how precession
was different than obliquity
or different than tilt.
Obliquity is how much
we're going from vertical.
And so if we had
no precession, we
would be exactly pointing in
that same direction every year.
Now, with just precession alone
what happens is every year
this arrow is slowly tracing out
a circle that goes like this.
So I'm going to
exaggerate how much it's
happening just so that
you can visualize it.
So maybe after several
years that arrow
is not-- when you're at that
same point relative to the sun,
that same point in
the solar system,
that arrow is no longer
pointing in that direction.
It is now traced out a
little bit of that circle.
So it is now pointing
in this direction.
So if it is now pointing
in this direction,
will that same point
in the solar system,
that same point relative to
the sun, that same exact point
in the orbit, will it
still be the summer
in the Northern Hemisphere?
Well, it won't because we're
now not pointing directly
or we're not most inclined
to the sun at that point.
Now, we would have
been most inclined
to the sun a little bit earlier
in the year or a little bit
earlier in the orbit.
So we would have been
most inclined to the sun
maybe over here.
And it would take many,
many, many actual thousands
of years for the precession
to change this much,
but then over here this is where
when at this point in that year
when we would be pointed
most towards the sun.
So what the real
effect of precession
is doing to our
seasons and doing
to what our sense of what our
year is, is that every year
relative to our orbit
on Earth, because Earth
is kind of a top
that's slowly circling,
that's slowly tracing
out this circle
with, I guess you could
say, with its pole.
What it's doing
is it's making it
tilt towards the sun
or away from the sun
a little bit earlier each year.
I know it's hard to
visualize, but you could even
take a top out and have
a basketball as the sun,
and if you play with it,
you'll see how that works.
And precession is another
one of those factors that
play into, I should say,
the Malinkovitch cycles.
And what we'll see is when
you combine precession,
when you combine-- or I should
say change in precession, when
you combine that
with changes in tilt,
and you combine that with
changes in actual how circular
or how elliptical the actual
orbit is and how that changes,
then you might have a
respectable way of explaining,
or some of explaining,
why Earth is entered
into these climactic cycles
over many tens of thousands
of years.